[Music]
a little winner want to land action for
you there we are two weeks and a day
away from christmas and the holiday
shipping rush is on the computer
software company adobe also tracks
shopping and says shoppers will spend
more than 80 billion dollars online in
december alone experts predict the
volume of online shopping and shipping
this season will break records cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell got inside a fedex
shipping facility in california for an
exclusive look at how the company plans
to deliver
all those packages on time for christmas
santa's helpers are hard at work in the
middle of the night at this fedex
processing facility in los angeles to
make sure your holiday gifts arrive on
time to some degree you are in santa's
workshop no doubt about it and like the
fedex plane is sort of like santa's
sleigh that that is the slag with nearly
60 percent of americans buying presents
online this year fedex expects to ship
an unprecedented 100 million more
packages this holiday season bobby
willis is vice president of operations
on the west coast how many packages will
you sort per hour
an hour we'll sort about 20 000 packages
an hour in this facility
that's incredible that adds up to 240
000 packages passing through this
facility alone
getting packages to their destination is
like a choreographed dance the amount of
packages that get sorted here in one day
is mind-blowing mind-blowing kyles
hawkins is a package handler and he says
during the holiday crush days are long
but they go by quickly so when these
packages are going by we want to make
sure that the labels are up so that
one's not up that was not up so we've
got to get that one up
these bins are designed to fit perfectly
on this boeing 767.
willis told us it takes about 30 minutes
to fill up this plane
what is the biggest challenge
biggest challenge for us right now is uh
just the the sheer amount of volume and
the planning that goes into moving that
volume all right bobby so given all
those challenges can you guarantee
people are going to get their packages
on time i can guarantee that if people
uh give us a correct address
make sure you get the zip code right get
the zip code right and ship early we
will get your package delivered on time
i can guarantee you that guaranteeing
smiles and laughs for many on christmas
morning
for cbs morning's norah o'donnell los
angeles
bobby's right you got to get that zip
code right and go norah o'donnell up at
3 30 in the morning she must miss these
hours